The elite end of the German Navy was the submarine corps. Those who served on subs during World War II were the best paid, the best fed, the smartest, the toughest. 1,100 submarines, they sunk 2,800 Allied ships. And of the German subs, the deadliest were the Type IX subs.
德国海军的精锐是潜艇部队。二战期间在潜艇上服役的人员薪水最高、伙食最好，也是最聪明、最强悍的。1100艘潜艇击沉了2800艘盟军船只。而在德国潜艇中，最致命的当属IX型潜艇。
You have the sound room and the radio room. To the right of that, we're going to go into our officers' quarters and into the kitchen where these two have already opted to cook for us today. Come on in. Watch your head.
这里是声纳室和无线电室。再往右走，我们将进入军官住舱和厨房，这两位已经在那里自告奋勇为我们做饭了。进来吧，注意别碰到头。
One of these subs, the U-505 there we has been on permanent display at Chicago's Museum of Science and Industry since the 1950s. It's stuffy, it's hot, and it's unbelievably cramped.
其中一艘潜艇，也就是那里的U-505，自20世纪50年代以来一直作为常设展品陈列在芝加哥科学与工业博物馆。这里闷热、狭窄得难以置信。
Now check this out. This is the kitchen for 59 guys.
现在看看这个，这是供59个人使用的厨房。
From the point of view of the Nazi government that built this sub, this right here is pretty much a worst-case scenario-- little black and brown-skinned children climbing through one of the most powerful machines of destruction pointing and laughing being interviewed, being interviewed by a Jewish reporter who has not entirely lost that pestering, nasal Jewish-y quality that was ever-so-annoying back in the fatherland. That is pretty much not the way they wanted the war to come out. Little American kids thinking that they could have served on this boat.
从建造这艘潜艇的纳粹政府的角度来看，眼前这场景简直是最糟糕的情况——皮肤黝黑和棕色的小孩子爬过这台最强大的毁灭机器之一，指指点点、嬉笑打闹，还接受采访，接受一位犹太记者的采访，而这位记者还没有完全摆脱当年在祖国时令人烦透了的那种恼人的、鼻音浓重的犹太腔。这绝对不是他们想要战争结束后的样子。美国小孩子竟然以为自己能在这种船上服役。
If I was on board, I would like to be the captain for all that ship.
如果我在船上，我想当整艘船的船长。
I want to be the captain.
我想当船长。
I want to be the person that walks around and checks around the whole boat.
我想做那个在船上走来走去巡视的人。
I want to be the person that carries the torpedoes and puts them in the thing and shoots them off.
我想做那个搬运鱼雷、把它放进发射管并把它们发射出去的人。
Now, believe it or not, we've just walked from our back part of our boat all the way up to the front. Are there any questions yet?
现在，不管你信不信，我们刚才从船尾一路走到了船头。现在有什么问题吗？
Yeah, how come if this was a German U-boat, how come most of this stuff is in English not German?
有，如果这是德国U型潜艇，为什么这些东西大多是英文而不是德文？
Do you speak German?
你会说德语吗？
No.
不会。
See, they're making it easy to help you.
你看，他们这是在方便你理解。
In fact, this kid is on to something. There are not many German words. There are no swastikas onboard, no reminders of Nazis at all, in fact. The thought that these were bunk beds where slept men who wanted to kill us, who sunk seven Allied ships themselves, who fought for the notion of an Aryan homeland and a master race, these unpleasant thoughts, they are not encouraged. And you know, maybe that is for the best.
事实上，这孩子说到了点子上。船上没几个德语单词。事实上，船上没有任何纳粹万字旗，也没有任何关于纳粹的提醒。想到这些双层床曾经睡过那些想杀死我们的人，他们自己击沉了七艘盟军船只，为雅利安家园和优等民族的理念而战，这些令人不快的想法，并没有被鼓励。你知道，也许这样最好。
Because I think if the museum would play up the evil, Nazi angle-- these are the dishes that the evil men ate from, this is their evil silverware. I think what they would lose in dignity, you can be sure they would gain dozens of times over in attendance. And how do I know this is true? Because, my friend, I have heard the story of Hitler's yacht, a fable if you will, a modern fable of what happens when the free market, the media, the World War II buffs, the neo-Nazis, and the Jews all collide over a huge Nazi tourist trap.
因为我觉得如果博物馆大肆渲染邪恶的纳粹角度——比如这些是邪恶之徒用餐的盘子，这是他们的邪恶餐具。我认为他们失去尊严的同时，肯定会获得多得多的参观人数。我怎么知道这是真的？因为，朋友，我听说过希特勒游艇的故事，或者说是一个寓言，一个关于自由市场、媒体、二战迷、新纳粹分子和犹太人在一个巨大的纳粹旅游陷阱面前发生碰撞时会发生什么的现代寓言。
We have devoted our entire program today to this story. It's kind of an amazing story. Alix Spiegel has spent months investigating Hitler's yacht, a craft whose original name was the Ostwind. For this hour she will be our guide. Here's Alix.
我们今天的整个节目都献给了这个故事。这是一个相当惊人的故事。阿利克斯·斯皮格尔花了几个月的时间调查希特勒的游艇，这艘船最初的名字叫“东风”号。接下来的一个小时里，她将担任我们的向导。有请阿利克斯。
There are things that we know and there are things that we don't know. We know that Hitler ordered it built in 1936 and that is cost a small fortune, close to $250,000. We know that it was completed in 1939, that each cabin was finished in a different fine wood, and that its sail, over 40 feet long, was made of a rare Egyptian linen.
有些事我们知道，有些事我们不知道。我们知道希特勒在1936年下令建造它，它花费不菲，接近25万美元。我们知道它于1939年完工，每个船舱都用了不同的高级木材装饰，其长达40多英尺的帆是由罕见的埃及亚麻布制成的。
We know that its designer was Heinrich Gruber, the most lauded naval architect at the time. And we know that its purpose was to demonstrate the superiority of the master race. But we don't know, we'll never be able to say with absolute certainty whether or not Hitler ever actually set foot on the Ostwind, or if this idea was just some twisted collective fantasy perpetuated for over half a century by celebrity-crazed Americans.
我们知道它的设计师是当时最受赞誉的海军建筑师海因里希·格鲁伯。我们也知道它的目的是展示优等民族的优越性。但我们不知道，我们也永远无法绝对肯定希特勒是否真的踏上过“东风”号，或者这个想法是否只是被迷恋名人的美国人维持了半个多世纪的一种扭曲的集体幻想。
Of course there were always rumors about the yacht. And some of those rumors were repeated so often that it's difficult now to distinguish them from fact. One of the rumors was that Hitler and his mistress, Eva Braun, used the Ostwind for pleasure cruises. Another is that Hitler had an extraordinary affection for the boat, that it was very important to him, and that when he talked about it, he always referred to it as his special lady.
当然，关于这艘游艇的传闻一直存在。其中一些传闻被重复了太多次，以至于现在很难将它们与事实区分开来。其中一个传闻是希特勒和他的情妇爱娃·布劳恩曾用“东风”号进行愉快的巡航。另一个传闻是希特勒对这艘船有着非同寻常的喜爱，它对他非常重要，当他谈论它时，总是称它为他“特别的女士”。
But there's no real evidence for any of this, just as there's no real evidence that Hitler's ghost continues to haunt the decks, or that the boat was used as a brothel by high-ranking Nazi officials, or that the yacht itself is cursed, that it will kill, maim, or financially decimate anyone unfortunate enough to own it. Although, on this last point at least, there does seem to be a series of suspiciously consistent anecdotes.
但这些都没有真正的证据，就像没有真正的证据表明希特勒的鬼魂继续在甲板上游荡，或者这艘船曾被纳粹高官用作妓院，或者游艇本身被诅咒了，会让任何不幸拥有它的人死亡、残废或倾家荡产。虽然至少在最后一点上，似乎确实有一系列令人怀疑的一致传闻。
This is the story of the last days of the Ostwind, one of two yachts built by the Nazi government after a poor German showing in the 1936 Olympic races. Even though its original purpose was to demonstrate the superiority of the German people in Olympic competition, the Ostwind actually spent most of its life in America, war booty transported here by the US Navy in 1947.
这是“东风”号最后日子的故事，它是纳粹政府在1936年奥运会比赛中德国表现不佳后建造的两艘游艇之一。尽管它最初的目的是为了展示德国人民在奥运会比赛中的优越性，但“东风”号实际上大部分时间是在美国度过的，它是美国海军在1947年作为战利品运到这里的。
I should tell you that when it arrived in this country, it wasn't known as Hitler's yacht. It became Hitler's yacht. More precisely, we made it Hitler's yacht. The Ostwind's sister ship, the Nordwind, a boat, mind you, with an identical pedigree, built at the same time by the same people for the same purpose, has never been known as Hitler's yacht. To this day, it sails in Britain under the name The White Rose, a charter boat which inspires no controversy, attracts no attention at all.
我得告诉你，当它到达这个国家时，它并不叫希特勒的游艇。它后来变成了希特勒的游艇。更准确地说，是我们把它变成了希特勒的游艇。“东风”号的姐妹船“北风”号，请注意，这艘船有着相同的血统，由同一群人在同一时间为了同一个目的建造，却从来没有被称为希特勒的游艇。直到今天，它还在英国以“白玫瑰”号的名字航行，这是一艘不引发任何争议、完全不引起注意的包租船。
But here in America, sometime in the 1950s, we made the Ostwind into Hitler's yacht. We made it into Hitler's yacht and then we sailed it, cursed it, set it on fire, restored it, tried to put it in a museum, stripped it to a skeleton, and finally sailed it into the Miami Harbor, and as a group of Holocaust survivors stood witness on the deck of a boat nearby, sank it to the bottom of the sea.
但在美国，20世纪50年代的某个时候，我们把“东风”号变成了希特勒的游艇。我们把它变成了希特勒的游艇，然后我们驾驶它、诅咒它、放火烧它、修复它、试图把它放进博物馆、把它拆成一副骨架，最后把它开进了迈阿密港，当一群大屠杀幸存者在附近船只的甲板上见证时，把它沉入了海底。
That road is a back road to the airport. Pecan Park there. Biscayne there, which runs into Dunn.
那条路是去机场的后路。那边是佩坎公园。那边是比斯坎大道，通往邓恩路。
J.J. Nelson has lived in Jacksonville, Florida, all his life on the Southside of town in a neighborhood called Panama Park. It's a modest neighborhood which borders the Trout River, a series of small ranch houses with water views and long docks stretching out behind them.
J.J.尼尔森一生都住在佛罗里达州的杰克逊维尔，住在城南一个叫巴拿马公园的街区。这是一个与鳟鱼河接壤的普通街区，有一排排的小型牧场风格房屋，有着水景和伸展在后面的长长码头。
J.J. owned one of those docks. He made his living renting boat space to wealthy weekenders who understood the pleasures of a fishing line and a cold beer. J.J., himself, was a fan of fishing lines and cold beer, particularly cold beer. He was a famous Jacksonville drunk.
J.J.拥有其中一个码头。他靠把船位租给那些懂得钓鱼和喝冰啤酒乐趣的有钱周末度假者为生。J.J.自己也是钓鱼和冰啤酒的爱好者，尤其是冰啤酒。他是杰克逊维尔著名的酒鬼。
Now this is not a past that J.J. is ashamed of, not at all. More than once he's told me, without a note of regret in his voice, that as a young man he had, and I quote, "the worst reputation from Miami to Virginia."
这并不是J.J.感到羞耻的过去，一点也不。他不止一次地告诉我，声音里没有一丝遗憾，年轻时他曾“拥有从迈阿密到弗吉尼亚最烂的名声”。
So I went down to Jacksonville to visit J.J. I spent two days in his truck listening to his extravagantly entertaining, occasionally appalling, and seemingly endless stories. J.J. is an excellent storyteller and a genius at Jacksonville history. He specializes in two particular kinds of narratives-- tails about crooked politicians thieving the public, and yarns about his own rather intimate experience with debauchery. Like the time J.J. tricked a man who had crossed him into marrying the woman that J.J. had tired of living with.
所以我去了杰克逊维尔拜访J.J.。我在他的卡车里待了两天，听着他那些极其有趣、偶尔令人震惊、似乎无穷无尽的故事。J.J.是一位出色的说书人，也是杰克逊维尔历史的天才。他专门讲述两种故事——关于腐败政客窃取公共财产的故事，以及关于他自己相当私密的放荡经历的故事。就像有一次，J.J.捉弄了一个得罪过他的人，让他娶了J.J.已经厌倦共同生活的那个女人。
She's really a nasty drunk, pretty but nasty. So I said, Johnny, you could come visit, but I said, my wife is a millionaire, she's a nymphomaniac. And she's an alcoholic. And it's all I can do to handle her. I can't put up with you. It don't seem like I hung the phone up, he was there.
她真是个讨厌的酒鬼，长得漂亮但很讨厌。所以我说，约翰尼，你可以来玩，但我说，我老婆是个百万富翁，她是个性欲亢进者。而且她还是个酒鬼。我能对付她就不错了。我没法忍受你。好像我还没挂断电话，他就已经在那里了。
So he came in. And he had been on a ship three years saving his money. So I went down in my office on the side of the house and I'd left her estate book out, which is about this thick of all the properties she owned, and land, and her money. And he had smoked a carton of cigarettes and put the ashtray, reading all of what she was worth. The next night she didn't come upstairs to bed. And I went down and they were both passed out together on the floor nude. I won't tell you what position. But he was about to choke. I said, he has bit the hook.
所以他进来了。他已经在船上工作了三年，攒了钱。我走进房子侧面的办公室，把她的资产账簿落在了外面，那本书大约这么厚，记录了她拥有的所有房产、土地和金钱。他抽了一整条烟，把烟灰缸填满，读完了她的身价。第二天晚上她没上楼睡觉。我下楼一看，他们俩都光着身子在地上醉倒了。我就不告诉你是什么姿势了。但他快要窒息了。我说，他上钩了。
There was a story about the time J.J. shot a man for dunking his dog underwater, a couple of stories, which involved J.J. falling off a bridge. And then there was the time that J.J. spent two drunk days on Danish shipper with an entire crew of female sailors.
还有一个故事是关于J.J.因为一个男人把他的狗按在水里淹而开枪打了那个男人，还有几个关于J.J.从桥上掉下来的故事。还有J.J.在丹麦货船上和整船的女船员喝了醉醺醺的两天的故事。
He had met two or three of the women crew members at a bar downtown, and after a night of drinking, accepted their invitation to continue the party back at the ship. The story from here follows a plot line familiar to any occasional viewer of hotel Pay-per-view. For two days J.J. stumbled from cabin to cabin to cabin having so much fun that he actually refused to leave the boat even after it left port.
他在市中心的一家酒吧遇到了两三个女船员，喝酒后，接受了她们的邀请去船上继续聚会。接下来的故事剧情，任何偶尔看酒店付费电视的人都会感到熟悉。两天里，J.J.跌跌撞撞地从一个船舱走进另一个船舱，玩得太开心了，以至于船离开港口后他竟然拒绝下船。
We got out just about the sea buoy, which is about a mile off the jetties in the ocean. And I had a new suit on, new shoes. I'd been to a big party. They got me dressed, got my clothes all on, my shoes, and they opened the door hatch. I figure, well hell-- you know how drunk is-- they're taking me to better quarters if it's possible. [BLEEP] they just opened the side hatch and threw me overboard, bam, in the ocean.
我们到了大约离海洋防波堤一英里的海标处。我穿了一套新西装，新鞋。我刚去参加了一个大型派对。他们帮我穿好衣服，穿上鞋子，然后打开了舱门。我想，见鬼——你知道喝醉的人是怎么想的——他们可能要带我去更好的船舱。该死，他们直接打开侧舱门把我扔进了海里，砰，掉进了大洋。
And then there's the story of Hitler's yacht, the most eye-popping, jaw-dropping story of all. The yacht arrived at J.J.'s dock in 1982.
还有一个故事是关于希特勒的游艇，这是所有故事中最让人瞠目结舌、下巴掉下来的一个。这艘游艇于1982年到达J.J.的码头。
I didn't realize it was anything special. It was an old half-rotted sailboat. It was worm-eaten and sunk down in the mud. And the decks were all right. But it was junk as far as I was concerned.
我当时没意识到它有什么特别。它是一艘半腐烂的旧帆船。它被虫蛀了，沉在泥里。甲板还好。但就我而言，它就是垃圾。
By the time the yacht made it to J.J.'s dock in Panama Park, it had had a number of American owners, I think around six or seven. Two had dropped dead of heart attacks shortly after buying the Ostwind. One had lost his left and part of his skull when he was hit in the face by the boat's mainsheet winch handle. There was a lawyer dude who supposedly used it for orgies, or prostitution, or something like that. And then there was Horace Glass.
当游艇到达J.J.的码头时，它已经有过几位美国主人了，我想大概六七个吧。有两人在买下“东风”号后不久就心脏病发作死了。一人在被船上的主帆绞盘手柄打中脸部时失去了左眼和部分头骨。还有个律师据说是用它来搞性爱派对、卖淫之类的。然后就是霍勒斯·格拉斯。
Horace Glass was a restoration enthusiast obsessed with a single purpose, to restore the Ostwind to its original glory and turn it into a floating museum of its own history. To reach this end, Glass sacrificed 14 years, $178,000, three homes, two businesses, and an antique camera collection. In other words, he bankrupted his family, lost almost everything they had ever owned.
霍勒斯·格拉斯是一位修复爱好者，痴迷于一个目标，那就是将“东风”号修复成往日的辉煌，并把它变成一座展示自身历史的漂浮博物馆。为了达到这个目的，格拉斯牺牲了14年时间、178,000美元、三处房产、两家企业和一套古董相机收藏。换句话说，他让家庭破产了，失去了他们几乎拥有的一切。
So after the whole floating museum idea didn't really work out, Horace needed a place to store the boat while he searched for a buyer. And this is how the Ostwind ended up at J.J.'s dock.
所以在整个漂浮博物馆的想法没能实现后，霍勒斯需要一个地方来存放这艘船，同时寻找买家。这就是“东风”号最终出现在J.J.码头的原因。
So he asked me, could he store the boat at my dock. And I said, yeah. And he brought it around on drums. There was hardly no bottom in it.
所以他问我，能不能把船存放在我的码头上。我说，可以。他用圆桶把它弄了过来。船底几乎没了。
Well after it had been there a couple of months, people started calling me and saying, do you know what kind of boat you've got there, whose boat that is? And I said, yeah. It's Horace Glass. And they said, no, that's Hitler's boat. And I said, my god.
在那停了几个月后，人们开始打电话给我说，你知道你那儿有什么样的船吗，那艘船是谁的？我说，知道，是霍勒斯·格拉斯的。他们说，不，那是希特勒的船。我说，天哪。
Horace, meanwhile, was busy trying to get his family out of hock. He placed a series of advertisements in papers all over the country. And those advertisements attracted a lot of attention. In particular, they attracted the attention of a man from Massachusetts.
与此同时，霍勒斯正忙着想办法让家人摆脱债务。他在全国各地的报纸上刊登了一系列广告。那些广告引起了很多人的注意。特别是引起了一位马萨诸塞州男子的注意。
Charles T. Sanderson of Kingston, Mass. He'd seen something about it. And he called and he arranged to buy the boat and get it off my property.
马萨诸塞州金斯顿的查尔斯·T·桑德森。他看到了一些相关消息。他打了电话，安排买下这艘船，把它从我的地盘上弄走。
Now Charles Sanderson of Kingston, Mass. was a man who'd been involved in a variety of questionable business dealings over the years. I have four solid interview tapes full of colorful examples, all of them highly libelous, half most likely exaggerated. A typical story involves a faux English businessman with fake accent, a historical landmark, Latin American smugglers, and a boat full of frozen flounder.
马萨诸塞州金斯顿的查尔斯·桑德森，多年来一直卷入各种可疑的商业交易。我有四盘扎实的采访录音，里面充满了丰富多彩的例子，所有这些都极具诽谤性，一半很可能是夸大的。一个典型的故事涉及一个假装有假口音的假英国商人、一个历史地标、拉美走私犯和一船冷冻比目鱼。
But there are other flounder-free claims against Charlie, several of which actually made it into the legal system. In 1991, Charlie was found guilty of defrauding the First National Bank of Boston for close to $1 million and was sentenced to a year in prison. It's fair to say that Charles Sanderson was a controversial character. He was also a memorabilia collector.
但还有其他针对查理的非比目鱼相关的索赔，其中几个甚至进入了法律系统。1991年，查理因诈骗波士顿第一国民银行近100万美元被判有罪，并被判入狱一年。可以说，查尔斯·桑德森是一个有争议的人物。他也是一位纪念品收藏家。
Airplanes, tanks, bazookas, handguns, medals, he's got a three-story house and I guarantee there's not a place in it you can't walk that there's that the Nazis made or had.
飞机、坦克、火箭筒、手枪、奖章，他有一座三层楼的房子，我敢保证里面没有一个地方没有纳粹制造或拥有的东西。
It wasn't just Nazi memorabilia, not at all. Charlie loved history and owned a huge number of historical artifacts. He specialized in materials from Admiral Richard E. Byrd's arctic exploration. So naturally when he read about the Ostwind in the paper, he immediately contacted Horace and made a deal.
这不仅仅是纳粹纪念品，一点也不。查理热爱历史，拥有大量的历史文物。他专门收藏理查德·E·伯德海军上将北极探险的材料。所以很自然地，当他在报纸上读到关于“东风”号的消息时，他立即联系了霍勒斯并达成了一笔交易。
Then Charlie went down to visit the boat at J.J.'s dock. When he arrived, he found it under 15 feet of water.
然后查理去J.J.的码头参观了这艘船。当他到达时，他发现它沉在15英尺深的水下。
After he'd spent about two weeks trying to get the boat up, he'd come to me in my office. He'd never spoke to me up until then. He was eating down in the restaurant and had his crew and he was staying in motels. So finally when he couldn't get the boat up because it was jammed between barges and a dock, he'd come to me and said, look here, what do you charge me to get that boat up? And I said, what are you going to do when you get it up? It's just going to sink again. He said, I'm going to take it to Boston.
在他花了大约两周时间试图把船打捞上来后，他来到我的办公室。在那之前他从没跟我说过话。他一直在餐厅吃饭，带着他的船员，住在汽车旅馆。最后，当他因为船卡在驳船和码头之间而无法打捞上来时，他来到我这说，听着，你收多少钱帮我把船弄上来？我说，你把它弄上来打算做什么？它只会再次沉下去。他说，我要把它带到波士顿去。
Like Horace, Charlie wanted to restore the boat and turn it into a museum. Specifically, Charlie proposed to display Hitler's yacht in the town of Plymouth, Massachusetts, at a location 15 minutes from the site where the Pilgrims first landed the Mayflower in 1620. It was an idea which didn't meet with much enthusiasm from the local population.
像霍勒斯一样，查理也想修复这艘船，并把它变成一座博物馆。具体来说，查理提议在马萨诸塞州的普利茅斯镇展示希特勒的游艇，地点距离1620年清教徒首次登陆“五月花号”的地方只有15分钟路程。这个想法并没有得到当地居民太多的热情响应。
City Council in Massachusetts or Plymouth had a meeting and wouldn't allow the boat in the state. That's a public record.
马萨诸塞州或普利茅斯的市议会举行了一次会议，不允许这艘船进入该州。这是公开记录。
The Boston Herald , Wednesday, March 20, 1985-- "Town fathers said yesterday that they would fight tooth and nail plans by a local developer to turn Adolf Hitler's yacht into a museum in the town where the Pilgrims landed the Mayflower. Local officials described the vessel as an affront to the Jewish community." "There are two chances we'll let that yacht in here," Plymouth Selectman, William Nolan, was quoted as saying, "slim and none".
《波士顿先驱报》，1985年3月20日星期三——“镇政要昨天表示，他们将竭尽全力阻止当地一位开发商将阿道夫·希特勒的游艇变成博物馆的计划，地点就在清教徒登陆五月花号的镇上。当地官员形容这艘船是对犹太社区的侮辱。”“我们允许那艘游艇进来的几率为二，”普利茅斯镇议员威廉·诺兰被引用说，“微乎其微”。
Charlie gave up on his plan to station Hitler's yacht at the landing place of the Pilgrims. But he didn't give up on his idea of returning the Ostwind to its former nautical majesty. He hired a famous yacht builder and undertook, what looked to J.J., like an extensive and very expensive restoration project.
查理放弃了将希特勒的游艇驻扎在清教徒登陆地的计划。但他没有放弃将“东风”号恢复往日航海威严的想法。他雇了一位著名的游艇建造商，开始了一项在J.J.看来既庞大又昂贵的修复工程。
There were men working on the boat at all hours. Each plank was carefully removed, sandblasted, and stored. Screws, bolts, rust, everything was saved.
工人们不分昼夜地在船上工作。每一块木板都被小心地拆除、喷砂处理并储存起来。螺丝、螺栓、铁锈，一切都被保存了下来。
What I didn't know until about two months later, one of the guys that worked for me said, you know what he's doing with those boards he's taking off , the planks? And I said, no. He's cutting them up, and marking them, selling them for souvenirs. I said, my god, who would buy them? He said, some of those little old boards are the size of a box of matches. He's getting $500 for them. And I had no idea that some damn fool would pay $500 for a little piece of teak.
大约两个月后我才知道，我手下的一个工人对我说，你知道他在怎么处理拆下来的那些木板吗？我说，不知道。他在把它们切开、标记，然后当纪念品卖掉。我说，天哪，谁会买它们？他说，有些老旧的小木板只有火柴盒大小。他卖了500美元一块。我根本没想到会有哪个大笨蛋愿意花500美元买一小块柚木。
Charlie would sit sometime for hours at the foot of the boat and talk to the Fuhrer, himself. In his mind he'd sit there and talk. And then he'd chatter about well, Hitler walked here. Hitler did this. The Fuhrer did this. The Fuhrer did that.
查理有时会坐在船底坐上几个小时，跟元首本人说话。在他脑子里，他坐在那儿说话。然后他喋喋不休地说，好吧，希特勒在这儿走过。希特勒做了这个。元首做了那个。元首做了这个。
Did you ever kind of confront him and say, you're crazy?
你有没有跟他对峙过，说他疯了？
Well I'm a cracker. I kind of thought it was funny. It's kind of like a circus your kid goes to. First time you see somebody walking around in a cage with lions, you kind of think it's funny and stupid at the same time. And it was kind of a circus really.
嗯，我是个乡巴佬。我觉得挺好笑的。就像你孩子去看的马戏团。第一次看到有人在笼子里和狮子一起走来走去，你既觉得好笑又觉得愚蠢。那真是一个马戏团。
I tried to talk to Charlie about the Ostwind. I called four or five times and asked for an interview. But Charlie wasn't interested. He told me he'd only owned the yacht for a brief period, five or six months at the most, which I knew wasn't true. But when I called him on it, he just denied it. He also denied that he had ever intended to station the yacht near Plymouth Rock no matter what the paper said. And he even denied that he owned an extensive antique collection.
我试过和查理谈谈“东风”号的事。我打了四五次电话要求采访。但查理没兴趣。他告诉我他只拥有过这艘游艇很短一段时间，最多五六个月，我知道这不是真的。但当我当面指出时，他只是否认。他还否认曾经打算把游艇停在普利茅斯岩附近，不管报纸怎么说。他甚至否认自己拥有庞大的古董收藏。
Then he told me that he could barely remember a thing about the boat. It was such a brief period so long ago. And that in any case, he had nothing of import to say about it. That was the phrase that he used, nothing of import.
然后他告诉我，他几乎记不起任何关于这艘船的事了。那是一段很久以前的短暂时期。无论如何，他没什么重要的事要说。那是他使用的短语，没有什么重要的事。
Charlie, I'm told, is a very pleasing person, a man with charisma you just can't resist. Lots of people told me this, even the ones he had ripped off. They described some terrible con Charlie pulled on them, then scratched their heads and tell me how much they still liked the guy, all the while staring off into space with a dazed expression like they'd just hit their head on something really hard and they were trying to figure out who they were and how they got here.
有人告诉我，查理是一个非常讨人喜欢的人，有着让你无法抗拒的魅力。很多人都这样告诉我，甚至是那些被他欺骗过的人。他们描述了查理对他们实施的一些可怕的骗局，然后挠挠头，告诉我他们仍然多么喜欢那个家伙，同时眼神茫然地看向远方，就像他们刚被什么重物砸到了头，正试图弄清楚自己是谁，怎么到这儿来的。
Charlie's magic certainly worked on J.J. After a couple of months they became friends and then business partners of sorts, which helps explain J.J.'s tolerance of some of Charlie's more unusual attitudes. You see, Charlie convinced J.J. that he was in a position to provide him with $50 million to develop the Trout River Waterfront into a high-end marine village, a dream which J.J. had harbored since he was a boy.
查理的魅力确实对J.J.起了作用。几个月后他们成了朋友，后来成了某种意义上的商业伙伴，这有助于解释J.J.对查理一些更不寻常态度的宽容。你看，查理说服J.J.说他有能力提供5000万美元，将鳟鱼河滨水区开发成一个高端的海滨村庄，这是J.J.从小就怀揣的梦想。
In return for this promise, J.J. drove Charlie around and introduced him to Jacksonville's rich, powerful, and political-- men Charlie viewed as potential business investors. There's actually a long and sordid story to tell about Charles Sanderson and his con of the city of Jacksonville, a story which begins when Charlie convinces the city to sell him a valuable downtown property at a vastly reduced price, claiming he would bring jobs and economic opportunity by installing a world-class military museum.
作为这个承诺的回报，J.J.开车带着查理到处走，把他介绍给杰克逊维尔的富人、权贵和政界人士——查理将这些人视为潜在的商业投资者。关于查尔斯·桑德森和他欺骗杰克逊维尔市的故事其实很长而且很肮脏，故事开始于查理说服该市以极低的价格将一处宝贵的市中心房产卖给他，谎称他将通过安装一个世界级的军事博物馆来带来就业和经济机会。
It ends, naturally, with a huge expose of Charlie and certain civic leaders in Jacksonville's newspaper, the Florida Times-Union. It turns out Charlie had neither the funds to pay for the property nor the objects he had promised to exhibit in the museum.
自然，结局是杰克逊维尔的报纸《佛罗里达州联合时报》对查理和某些市政领导进行了一次大曝光。事实证明，查理既没有钱支付房产，也没有他承诺在博物馆展出的展品。
So Charlie was run out of town. And J.J., through grit, and cunning, and a certain amount of river rat guile, ended up inheriting Hitler's yacht. Unlike Charlie or Horace, J.J. had no great plan for the boat. And so it sat, a rotting ghost of a promise made long ago on a piece of land near J.J.'s dock for close to two years until some neighborhood boys came by and decided that Hitler's yacht was an ideal place to start a fire.
所以查理被赶出了城。而J.J.凭借毅力、狡诈和某种河鼠般的狡猾，最终继承了希特勒的游艇。不像查理或霍勒斯，J.J.对这艘船没有任何宏伟的计划。于是它就那么坐着，作为一个早已被遗忘的承诺的腐烂鬼魂，在J.J.码头附近的土地上停了近两年，直到几个街区男孩跑来，决定希特勒的游艇是一个放火的好地方。
When these kids set it afire, the deck afire, at one corner, then people were scared to tie their boats to the dock. Because if one boat catches afire at a dock with all that gasoline, then they all burn. So then people wouldn't tie their boat there because they were afraid their boat would catch afire. Because they were afraid people would come set that boat afire and catch their boat afire.
当这些孩子点燃它，甲板在一个角落着火时，人们就害怕把船系在码头上了。因为如果有一艘船在码头着火，带着所有的汽油，那么所有的船都会烧毁。所以人们就不愿意把船系在那里，因为他们怕自己的船会着火。因为他们怕别人会来把那艘船点着，连累他们的船也着火。
We had a very popular restaurant right nearby the dock, Jackie's, the original. Not where it is now. And then people started walking out and saying, oh, is this the boat, a lot of big shots, the higher class of people. And they started telling my sister, you ought to get that boat off this dock. It's just a terrible thing to have that boat here. And you know how things stockpile and keep blowing and getting bigger.
我们在码头附近有一家非常受欢迎的餐厅，最初的杰基餐厅。不是现在的位置。然后人们开始走出来说，哦，这是那艘船吗，许多大人物，更高阶层的人。他们开始告诉我姐姐，你应该把那艘船从码头上弄走。把那艘船放在这里真是一件可怕的事情。你知道事情是怎么堆积起来并不断膨胀变大的。
After the fire, a whole cast of odd and blighted characters began to visit the boat. There was the Holocaust survivor whose wife had died in a concentration camp and who claimed that when he stood near the yacht, he could hear the voice of his long dead love. And then there was the old woman with a portable plastic lawn chair.
火灾后，一群古怪而落魄的角色开始光顾这艘船。有一位大屠杀幸存者，他的妻子死在了集中营里，他声称当他站在游艇旁时，能听到他长眠的爱人的声音。还有一位拿着便携式塑料草坪椅的老妇人。
German lady, and she spoke mostly German. And she would set there by the boat in a chair. She'd bring her chair and hold on to the boat and pray that she could feel the presence of the Fuhrer. So she would scrape little pieces of paint off the boat for souvenirs.
德国女士，她主要说德语。她会坐在椅子上靠近船。她会带着椅子，扶着船，祈祷能感受到元首的存在。所以她会从船上刮下一些小碎片作为纪念品。
One person had come down to the dock and pulled a piece of plank, and off and run up the dock and fell and broke his leg. He could have had the wood as far as I was concerned. But he thought he was stealing it. So we had to put a guard on the dock to keep people from vandalizing it or tearing up other people's boats.
有人来到码头上，拉了一块木板，跑上码头跌倒摔断了腿。只要他愿意，他可以拿走木头。但他以为自己在偷东西。所以我们不得不派人看守码头，防止人们破坏它或拆毁别人的船。
Even with the guard there were problems, fights, and thieves, and all kinds of strange people who appeared out of the woodwork, drawn for very personal, private reasons to what Hitler represented.
即使有警卫，仍然有麻烦、打架、小偷和各种奇怪的人从阴影里冒出来，因为非常个人、隐私的原因被希特勒所代表的东西所吸引。
Where were you born?
你在哪里出生的？
I was born in a small city in Lithuania, Rokiskis.
我出生在立陶宛的一个小城市，罗基什基斯。
And what was your date of birth?
你的出生日期是什么？
My date of birth was 2/27/1924.
我的出生日期是1924年2月27日。
The very personal, private reasons which drew Abe Resnick to Hitler's yacht can be found in a mass grave near Rokiskis, Lithuania, his father, his mother, his two sisters.
吸引阿比·雷斯尼克到希特勒游艇上来那些非常私人的理由，可以在立陶宛罗基什基斯附近的一个乱葬岗中找到，那里有他的父亲、母亲和两个姐姐。
In this interview with the Shoah Foundation, Abe describes the death of his family. He also talks about watching his neighbors dig their own graves, and saving his grandmother from some prison guards, and wandering for days in the woods cold, afraid, and half mad with hunger after escaping from his German captors in 1941.
在这次与肖亚基金会的采访中，阿比描述了他家人的死亡。他还谈到看着邻居们挖掘自己的坟墓，从一些监狱看守手中救下他的祖母，以及在1941年从德国俘虏手中逃脱后在森林里徘徊了几天，寒冷、恐惧，饿得半疯。
After his escape, Abe joined the Russian Army looking, he says, for revenge. And in a way, he found it. He was in one of the first army units to come across Hitler's bunker, the site of Hitler's last days and death by suicide immediately after the fall of Berlin.
逃脱后，阿比加入了苏联军队，他说，为了复仇。在某种程度上，他找到了。他是第一批偶然发现希特勒地堡的军队部队之一，那是希特勒柏林陷落后最后日子和自杀的地方。
You should have seen the inside of the bunker. I mean, it was amazing. I didn't have a camera to shoot pictures. But it was a little city was in the city. And I want to mention to you that we have seen the corpses, the burning corpses of Eva Braun and of Adolf Hitler. It was an incredible experience for us, especially for those, the Jews who were in the camps.
你应该看看地堡里面。我的意思是，太惊人了。我没有相机拍照片。但这就像是一个城市里的一个小城市。我想告诉你，我们看到了尸体，爱娃·布劳恩和阿道夫·希特勒燃烧的尸体。这对我们来说是一次不可思议的经历，特别是对于那些在集中营里的犹太人来说。
In 1985, 40 years after Abe stood over what he believed was the burned corpse of Adolf Hitler, he got a call from a rabbi in Mandarin, Florida. At the time, Abe was a real estate developer and the Vice-Mayor of Miami Beach. He was also very active in the movement to keep the memory of the Holocaust alive. So active that the street next to the Holocaust Memorial in Miami is called the Abe Resnick Boulevard.
1985年，在阿比站在他认为是阿道夫·希特勒烧焦尸体的地方40年后，他接到了佛罗里达州曼达林一位拉比的电话。当时，阿比是一位房地产开发商和迈阿密海滩的副市长。他也非常积极地参与让大屠杀记忆永存的运动。他如此积极，以至于迈阿密大屠杀纪念馆旁边的街道被称为“阿比·雷斯尼克大道”。
So it was only natural for the rabbi to call Abe, only natural for the rabbi to ask Abe what he thought should be done about the problems presented by Hitler's yacht-- the constant traffic, the freak show atmosphere. It turned out Abe did have an idea for the boat. And after talking to the rabbi, he flew to Jacksonville to discuss his idea with J.J.
所以拉比打电话给阿比是很自然的，拉比问阿比他认为应该如何处理希特勒游艇带来的问题——持续的交通、畸形秀的氛围，也是很自然的。事实证明，阿比确实对这艘船有一个想法。在和拉比谈过之后，他飞往杰克逊维尔与J.J.讨论他的想法。
Well he came up and asked me what I wanted to do with it, what did I think about doing with it. I said, well I had some offers. And we had dinner at my sister's restaurant, Jackie's, the original one on Trout River, and spent the afternoon talking and walking.
嗯，他过来问我我想怎么处理它，我对此有什么想法。我说，嗯，我有几个报价。我们在我姐姐的餐厅，鳟鱼河上的最初那家杰基餐厅吃了顿晚餐，下午谈论着并散步。
And he was telling me, what did your daddy do? And I told him he was a seaman. And he said, well what do you think he would want this thing-- you know, he's good salesman-- he said, he's dead. Don't you think it'd be kind of a disgrace to give this something that represents this much tyranny and horror to the world and make a shrine out of it? I said, well, you're absolutely right. He said, let me tell you what I'd like to do with it. And he told me.
他告诉我，你爸爸是做什么的？我告诉他他是个海员。他说，好吧，你觉得他会想让这东西——你知道，他是个好推销员——他说，他死了。难道你不觉得把这种向世界代表了这么多暴政和恐怖的东西当成神社来供奉是一种耻辱吗？我说，嗯，你说的非常对。他说，让我告诉你我想怎么处理它。然后他告诉了我。
Abe wanted to sink Hitler's yacht in the Miami Harbor, to blow it up while a group of Holocaust survivors watched from a boat nearby. He thought this act would provide the survivors with some kind of closure, with a sense that we now lived in a very different world.
阿比想把希特勒的游艇沉入迈阿密港，在一群大屠杀幸存者在附近船上观看时把它炸掉。他认为这一行为会给幸存者带来某种解脱，让他们感觉到我们现在生活在一个非常不同的世界里。
Abe told J.J. he wanted to plan the sinking to coincide with the 50th anniversary of the Voyage of the Damned, when 900 Jewish refugees on board a ship called the St. Louis were denied entrance to the United States and forced to return to Europe. About 700 of the 900 Jewish passengers were slaughtered in concentration camps. And the idea was to collect whatever survivors there were and maybe some other dignitaries, perhaps even some Nobel Prize winners, and sail them all out to the point in the Miami Harbor where the St. Louis had been turned away. At that point, at that point exactly, they would demonstrate to themselves and to anyone else who'd cared to notice that the tide had certainly changed. In the words of Abe Resnick, words which were quoted extensively after his meeting with J.J. became public, "We intend to apply the final solution. We intend to apply the final solution to Hitler's yacht."
阿比告诉J.J.他想计划让沉船的时间与“被诅咒的航行”50周年纪念日重合，当时900名乘坐“圣路易斯号”的犹太难民被拒绝进入美国，被迫返回欧洲。900名犹太乘客中约有700人在集中营被屠杀。想法是收集所有的幸存者，也许还有一些政要，甚至是一些诺贝尔奖得主，把他们都航行到迈阿密港“圣路易斯号”被拒之门外的那一点。就在那一点，确切的那一点，他们将向自己和任何关心的旁观者证明，局势确实已经改变了。用阿比·雷斯尼克的话说，在他与J.J.的会面公开后，这些话被广泛引用，“我们打算实施最终解决方案。我们打算对希特勒的游艇实施最终解决方案。”
It was certainly better to sink that boat off in Miami where it would do some good for some fish to breed and reproduce than to put it somewhere and make a shrine for a bunch of skinhead Nazis. In America we don't believe in that kind of stuff. So I said, all right. It sounds like a good idea to me. He said, well, what do you want to do with it? I said, well, I guess I'll give to you then. He said, you know people are going to offer you more money now that I want it. I said, do we need a contract? And he said, you shook my hand. I said, yeah. He said, then that's all the contract we need, ain't it? And I said, absolutely with me if it's all right with you.
把那艘船沉在迈阿密，让鱼儿繁殖产卵，总比把它放在某个地方为一群光头党纳粹分子建造一座神社要好。在美国，我们不信那一套。所以我说，好吧。这听起来是个好主意。他说，那你打算怎么处理它？我说，嗯，那我想我把它交给你吧。他说，既然我想要它，现在会有人给你出更多的钱。我说，我们需要一份合同吗？他说，你握过我的手。我说，是的。他说，那这就是我们需要的全部合同，不是吗？我说，如果你没意见，我完全同意。
This is what is left of Adolf Hitler's once glorious yacht-- rotting wood, rusted steel, broken glass. It's enough, though, to remind a concentration camp survivor of Hitler's evils and to want the boat destroyed.
这就是阿道夫·希特勒曾经辉煌的游艇所剩下的——腐烂的木头、生锈的钢、破碎的玻璃。不过，这足以提醒一位集中营幸存者希特勒的邪恶，并让他想要摧毁这艘船。
That handshake got a lot of press. Jackie Judd from ABC News did a whole story about it. She explained how Hitler would stroll the decks of the Ostwind with his mistress, Eva Braun, and talked to a couple hollow-eyed Holocaust survivors who seemed to think that this sinking was a good idea.
那次握手受到了很多媒体关注。ABC新闻的杰基·贾德做了一个完整的故事。她解释了希特勒是如何带着情妇爱娃·布劳恩在“东风”号的甲板上散步的，并采访了几个目光空洞的大屠杀幸存者，他们似乎认为沉船是个好主意。
Then J.J. got up and shook Abe's hand again, only this time they did it in front of the cameras. They promised that within the year, Hitler's yacht would be at the bottom of the Miami Harbor, nothing more than a playground for interested marine life. And this is when the trouble really began.
然后J.J.站起来再次握了阿比的手，只有这一次他们是在摄像机前做的。他们承诺在一年内，希特勒的游艇将沉入迈阿密港底部，只不过是感兴趣的海洋生物的游乐场。也就是从这时起，麻烦真的开始了。
Coming up, lawyers, guns, and money, lots and lots of money, neo-Nazi money, in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，律师、枪支和金钱，大量大量的金钱，新纳粹的金钱，公共广播国际公司节目继续，稍后回来。
Its This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Today we are devoting our entire program to the story of the boat known as Hitler's yacht. Alix Spiegel continues the story.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们将整个节目献给被称为希特勒游艇的那艘船的故事。阿利克斯·斯皮格尔继续讲述这个故事。
The market for Hitler and Nazi memorabilia, as far as anyone can tell, is relatively modest, in the millions each year. And what dealers of these materials will tell you is that while a small percentage of their business is Nazi sympathizers, the vast bulk of the market is history buffs, the kind of people who can recite every battle in the Civil War.
据任何人所知，希特勒和纳粹纪念品的市场相对适中，每年只有数百万美元。这些材料的交易商会告诉你，虽然他们的一小部分业务来自纳粹同情者，但绝大部分市场是历史爱好者，那种能背诵内战中每一场战役的人。
Hitler's yacht seemed to capture the imagination of these collectors and a lot of other people too, particularly after the boat appeared on television alongside Abe, J.J., and Jackie Judd.
希特勒的游艇似乎捕捉到了这些收藏家和许多其他人的想象力，特别是在这艘船出现在电视上，与阿比、J.J.和杰基·贾德一起出现之后。
After that people really started sending letters, telegrams-- I've got boxes of them here-- of some wanting to buy it to preserve it, some thinking it was a good idea to destroy it, some thought they ought to burn it right there. And there were threats made in every direction.
在那之后，人们真的开始寄信、电报——我这儿有成箱的——有的想买下它来保存，有的认为销毁它是个好主意，有的认为他们应该直接在那儿把它烧了。而且各个方向都有威胁。
There were angry letters from historical preservationists and angrier letters from neo-Nazis.
有来自历史保护主义者的愤怒信件，还有来自新纳粹分子的更愤怒的信件。
They're not going to kill you. But they just say that. Nazis are spineless anyway. They probably could beat up some old woman or something. But it's not an easy thing to go kill somebody that's prepared.
他们不会杀了你。但他们只是那么说。纳粹本来就是没有骨气的。他们可能也就是能欺负一下老妇人什么的。但去杀一个有准备的人可不是件容易的事。
And so J.J. got prepared. He stopped going out at night and refused to meet strangers unless they agreed to meet at his house.
所以J.J.做好了准备。他不再在晚上出门，拒绝见陌生人，除非他们同意在自己家里见面。
I just changed a few of my habits. I didn't eat at the same restaurants. I didn't, like I said, go out in the evenings or meet strangers. Of course I had fences, dogs, and security, and proper firearms myself.
我只是改掉了我的一些习惯。我不去同一家餐厅吃饭。我不像我说的，晚上出门或见陌生人。当然我有栅栏、狗和安保，我自己也有适当的枪支。
Despite these precautions, there were incidents. One of the windows in J.J.'s house was shot out during a midnight drive-by. And there was a similar attack on his office. Because J.J. is J.J., these late night shootings didn't really make much of an impression. In fact, I first learned about the shootings not from J.J. himself-- he forgot to tell me-- but from his companion, a woman named Linda he's known since he was a teenager. Of course, Linda didn't seem particularly impressed either.
尽管有这些预防措施，还是发生了事件。J.J.家的一扇窗户在午夜一次驾车枪击中被打碎了。他的办公室也受到了类似的攻击。因为J.J.就是J.J.，这些深夜枪击事件并没有真正给他留下太深刻的印象。事实上，我第一次知道这些枪击事件不是从J.J.本人那里——他忘了告诉我——而是从他的伴侣，一个他十几岁时就认识的叫琳达的女人那里。当然，琳达似乎也没留下什么深刻印象。
I recall one particular night, someone drove by his office and shot a gun. And I said, small caliber.
我记得特别的一个晚上，有人开车经过他的办公室开了一枪。我说，小口径。
It was just a small caliber. It was a .22. It wasn't a big gun. Hell, it might have even been one of my neighbors. But they called up and took credit for it.
那只是一个小口径。它是.22口径。不是什么大枪。见鬼，甚至可能是我的邻居干的。但他们打电话来承担了责任。
When somebody shoots one of my windows out, I just move my chair over to another spot in the house and board that window up.
当有人把我的窗户打碎时，我就把椅子搬到房子的另一个地方，把那扇窗户封起来。
At this point in our story as events begin to spiral, I'd like to take a moment to point out just how unlikely it is that the Ostwind was actually used by Adolf Hitler. Horace Glass, the man who first brought the boat to J.J.'s dock, not only went broke trying to restore the yacht, he also spent over 20 years collecting information about the Ostwind's history. He hunted down newspaper articles, blueprints. He even initiated a correspondence with Nazi architect Albert Speer.
在故事的这一点，当事件开始盘旋上升时，我想花点时间指出，“东风”号实际上被阿道夫·希特勒使用过的可能性有多么小。霍勒斯·格拉斯，第一个把船带到J.J.码头的人，不仅为了修复游艇而破产，他还花了20多年时间收集关于“东风”号历史的信息。他搜寻报纸文章、蓝图。他甚至与纳粹建筑师阿尔伯特·斯佩尔通信。
But the closest he came to proof that the yacht ever felt the weight of Hitler's foot is this: the German shipbuilders who constructed the Ostwind, people who had never met Adolf Hitler themselves, told him that they were told that the boat was very important to the Fuhrer. That's it.
但他所能找到的最接近希特勒确实踏上过游艇的证据是：建造“东风”号的德国造船商，那些本人从未见过阿道夫·希特勒的人，告诉他，有人告诉他们这艘船对元首非常重要。仅此而已。
And although the Ostwind was built for Olympic yacht racing, almost immediately after its completion it was painted gray and used in the war effort, mostly hauling stuff back and forth for the German Navy. So it's hard to imagine that it got much use as a pleasure craft.
虽然“东风”号是为奥林匹克帆船赛建造的，但它完工后几乎立即就被刷成了灰色并用于战争工作，大部分时间是为德国海军运送物资。所以很难想象它被用作休闲游艇的机会很多。
After going through 50 years of newspaper clippings about the Ostwind, I can tell you this. When the boat arrived in America in the 1940s, it was advertised as the yacht of Admiral Karl Donitz, Commander-in-Chief of the German Navy, a claim which was probably also untrue.
在翻阅了50年来关于“东风”号的剪报后，我可以告诉你这一点。当这艘船在20世纪40年代到达美国时，它被宣传为德国海军总司令卡尔·邓尼茨海军上将的游艇，这一说法很可能也是不真实的。
Later in the decade, an enterprising Baltimorean dubbed the Ostwind the Nazi yacht and sold tours to visitors in the Baltimore Harbor. So it wasn't until the 1950s that the Ostwind became known as Hitler's yacht, probably for simple commercial reasons.
在该十年晚些时候，一位足智多谋的巴尔的摩人给“东风”号起名纳粹游艇，并向巴尔的摩港的游客兜售游览。所以直到20世纪50年代，“东风”号才被冠以希特勒游艇之名，很可能只是出于简单的商业原因。
In light of this evidence that the Ostwind was probably not Hitler's yacht, the events which follow are all the more incredible.
鉴于这些证据表明“东风”号很可能不是希特勒的游艇，接下来的事件就更令人难以置信了。
We started getting inquiries from all over the world. I recall seeing an inquiry fro-- China.
我们开始收到来自世界各地的询问。我记得看到过一个来自……中国的询问。
Maine, New York, Tallahassee, Alabama, Mexico, New Mexico, Texas-- we got stacks of cards.
缅因州、纽约、塔拉哈西、阿拉巴马、墨西哥、新墨西哥、德克萨斯——我们收到了成堆的卡片。
And it was people who normally I don't think had an interest particularly in ships and sailing.
而且那些人我通常认为对船只和航海并没有特别的兴趣。
"Dear Mr. Nelson, I talked with you two weeks ago about the abandoned Ostwind. I'm with a nonprofit group called the Keike Enrichment Foundation. We put on special programs and events for Hawaii's handicapped children. We just had a Christmas event for the Shriners Hospital down the way. There was tons of snow, crushed ice, and a snowman building contest that was really fun. Anyway, we're a new organization and thought the Ostwind might make an interesting exhibit for the kids. Any idea what you're going to do with the boat? Please advise."
“亲爱的尼尔森先生，我两周前和你谈过那艘废弃的“东风”号。我来自一个叫“凯克丰富基金会”的非营利组织。我们为夏威夷的残疾儿童举办特别项目和活动。我们刚在附近的施纳医院举办了圣诞活动。那里有大量的雪、碎冰和堆雪人比赛，真的很有趣。无论如何，我们是一个新组织，认为“东风”号可能成为孩子们的一个有趣的展览品。有什么打算处理这艘船的想法吗？请告知。”
"Dear Mr. Nelson, I realize that my interest in the Ostwind yacht is probably not unique. I'm sure you have plenty of people calling with offers, et cetera. But please allow me to make a case for myself. My wish to restore the craft is driven by my need for a project to occupy myself during the long illness I have. I am young, 32, and on social security for the rest of my life. So I thought it would be fun to restore a part of history that could otherwise be lost forever. My funds are low but regular as clockwork. And I promise I will work very, very hard."
“亲爱的尼尔森先生，我知道我对“东风”号游艇的兴趣可能并不独特。我肯定你有很多人打电话来报价等等。但请允许我为自己辩护。我修复这艘船的愿望是出于我需要一个项目在我患病期间占据我的时间。我很年轻，32岁，余生都在领取社会保障金。所以我认为修复一段可能永远消失的历史会很有趣。我的资金很少但像时钟一样准时。我保证我会非常非常努力地工作。”
There were other letters, boxes upon boxes of them stored in the mobile home parked behind J.J.'s house. They were from people who couldn't understand what all the fuss was about or people who thought that the boat should be burned where it stood. Every state, every race, every position and policy was represented, usually it was represented emphatically. And the violence at the emotions puzzled J.J.
还有其他的信件，成箱的信件存放在J.J.家后面的移动房里。它们来自那些不明白这有什么好大惊小怪的人，或者是认为这艘船应该当场烧掉的人。每个州、每个种族、每个立场和政策都有代表，通常他们表达得非常激烈。这些情绪中的暴力令J.J.感到困惑。
I mean, I couldn't see how a resting relic of a piece of junk boat could mean so many different things to different people. In other words, the Jewish people hated it because it belonged to Adolf Hitler. And they wanted it destroyed and gotten rid of because of some psychological connection of Hitler. And the Nazis and the skinheads looked at it as a shrine like a holy place. And it was just a boat.
我的意思是，我看不出这样一个休息的垃圾船遗迹怎么会对不同的人意味着这么多不同的东西。换句话说，犹太人讨厌它，因为它属于阿道夫·希特勒。他们想销毁它并摆脱它，因为希特勒有某种心理联系。而纳粹分子和光头党把它看作一个神社，像一个神圣的地方。而它只是一艘船。
Then J.J. got another letter. Or actually J.J.'s lawyer got another letter. It was from a neo-Nazi group in the Midwest. They wanted to buy the Ostwind.
然后J.J.又收到了一封信。或者实际上J.J.的律师收到了一封信。它是来自中西部的一个新纳粹团体。他们想买“东风”号。
After I had handshook and gave it to Commissioner Resnick on the deck of the boat in front of ABC News, Jackie Judd, they contacted the lawyer and offered a half a million dollars for the boat.
在我与雷斯尼克专员在ABC新闻杰基·贾德面前的船甲板上握手并把它交给他们之后，他们联系了律师，并为这艘船报价50万美元。
And what did you think when you heard that?
当你听到这个时，你是怎么想的？
Well, half a million dollars is nice to have. But it wasn't that important. First of all, I already gave the boat to the Jewish people, Resnick. So I couldn't go back on my word. And their idea was you didn't sign any papers. I said, no. But I shook hands with the man. And I gave him my word.
嗯，50万美元是很不错。但它没那么重要。首先，我已经把船交给了犹太人，雷斯尼克。所以我不能食言。他们的想法是，你没签任何文件。我说，没有。但我跟那个人握了手。我给了他我的承诺。
But the offer created its own problems. J.J.'s sister Jackie, owner of the original Jackie's restaurant on Trout River, had died a couple of summers before when the cigarette she was smoking set fire to her bed. Her death left the family in debt, a towering mountain of debt, including a sizable bill to the corporate lawyer in charge of her estate. Here's Linda.
但这笔报价本身就制造了问题。J.J.的姐姐杰基，鳟鱼河上最初的杰基餐厅的所有者，在几年前夏天去世了，当时她吸烟的烟头引燃了她的床。她的去世让家庭陷入了债务，一座高耸入云的债务之山，包括欠她遗产负责人企业律师的一笔可观账单。这是琳达。
The attorney for her estate actually sued him to try to keep him from giving the boat away.
她遗产的律师实际上起诉了他，试图阻止他把船送人。
He was indignant and mad because I gave away a corporate asset for a half a million dollars for nothing, he said, which was bad business. I said, well it's a matter of principle, not so much the money. Of course I could have used the money. But like I said, I already gave it to the man. So I couldn't very well change my mind if I wanted to.
他很愤慨，很生气，因为我把一笔价值50万美元的企业资产免费送人了，他说，这是糟糕的生意。我说，好吧，这是一个原则问题，而不是钱的问题。当然我本来可以用这笔钱的。但就像我说的，我已经把它交给那个人了。所以即使我想，我也不能轻易改变主意。
Florida Times-Union May 31, 1989. "Hitler's yacht was moved by barge from the Trout River to the Intracoastal Waterway during the weekend and is scheduled to begin its final voyage today. 'Finally', said Rabbi Gary Perez of Beth Shalom Congregation in Mandarin. 'Hitler's yacht is getting what it deserves."
《佛罗里达州联合时报》1989年5月31日。“希特勒的游艇周末被驳船从鳟鱼河移至内陆水道，计划今天开始其最后航行。“终于”，曼达林贝斯·沙洛姆会众的拉比加里·佩雷斯说。“希特勒的游艇得到了它应得的。”
When the boat was being transported to Miami by barge, they had threats-- like at St. Augustine, there's a narrow bridge at 210. And some people called and said they were going to blow it up. People on the boat were watching. It never stopped. It just went day and night straight through in the waterway.
当船被驳船运往迈阿密时，他们受到了威胁——比如在圣奥古斯丁，210号公路上有一座狭窄的桥。一些人打电话说他们要把它炸了。船上的人都在看着。它从没停过。它在水道里日夜不停地直行。
My lawyer was calling every 15 minutes when the boat was going down the river telling me I was making a terrible mistake. And I wouldn't have a pot or a window when he got through.
当船顺流而下时，我的律师每隔15分钟就打一次电话，告诉我我犯了一个可怕的错误。等他弄完，我连个锅或窗户都不会剩下。
On June 4, 1989, over 100 people, including 27 survivors of the Voyage of the Damned, boarded a Princess Line cruiser to witness the sinking of the Ostwind yacht. As an airplane passed overhead towing a sign branded with the words "never again", the cruiser set sail.
1989年6月4日，包括27名“被诅咒的航行”幸存者在内的100多人登上一艘公主线游轮，见证“东风”号游艇的沉没。当一架飞机在头顶经过，拖着一条印有“永不再发生”字样的横幅时，游轮启航了。
Rabbi Barry Konovitch of the Aventura Turnberry Jewish Center in Miami was at the sinking of the yacht. Was, in fact, one of the event's organizers. He says that the cruiser trolled back and forth in the harbor for about an hour before the sinking. They wanted to give the survivors time to absorb the meaning of the day.
迈阿密阿文图拉特恩伯里犹太中心的拉比巴里·科诺维奇在游艇沉没现场。实际上，他是该活动的组织者之一。他说，在沉没前，游轮在港口徘徊了大约一个小时。他们想给幸存者时间去领会这一天的意义。
Then we came to the point where the yacht hove into view. And there was an announcement on the loudspeaker by the captain, what was about to happen, that everybody should go out on deck. And all of a sudden, there was a tremendous quiet that settled over the boat. Nobody said a word. And I must tell you that when the moment came for the yacht to be observed and then sunk, one person turned around, and then another person turned around. And the entire deck just turned their backs on the ship. They didn't even want to look at it as a symbolic gesture.
然后我们来到了游艇进入视野的地方。船长的扩音器上发布了一个通知，关于即将发生的事情，每个人都应该到甲板上去。突然，船上安静得可怕。没人说话。我必须告诉你，当观察游艇并随后将其沉没的时刻到来时，一个人转过身去，接着另一个人转过身去。整个甲板的人都背对着那艘船。他们甚至不想看它，这是一种象征性的姿态。
Before the ship went down?
在船沉下去之前？
As it was about to go down. And I don't remember any cheering. I just remember the silence.
在它即将沉没的时候。我不记得有什么欢呼声。我只记得那片沉默。
And why do you think that they did that?
你认为他们为什么那么做？
They wanted to demonstrate rather graphically their revulsion at the Nazis and at Nazism. And this was the symbol that represented Nazism to them at that moment.
他们想非常形象地展示他们对纳粹和纳粹主义的厌恶。而这一刻，这就是代表纳粹主义的象征。
And it wasn't choreographed or anything?
而且这不是精心编排的什么东西？
Not at all. It was just an amazing thing. Spontaneous.
一点也不。这只是一件了不起的事情。自发的。
Spontaneous disgust.
自发的厌恶。
Yes.
是的。
Abe Resnick died in 1998. But I talked to his son, Jimmy Resnick, who attended the ceremony with his mother.
阿比·雷斯尼克于1998年去世。但我与他的儿子吉米·雷斯尼克谈过，他和母亲一起参加了仪式。
It sank. Everybody threw flowers or lilies or whatever into the ocean. And everybody started screaming. I believe, then, we went into a rendition of-- I believe if I'm not mistaken-- the Hatikva and then the National Anthem. And people started to sing and started to hug each other. And it was very touching, very very touching.
它沉了。每个人都向大海扔了花或百合花之类的东西。每个人都开始尖叫。我相信，然后我们开始了一场——如果我没记错的话——《哈提克瓦》，然后是国歌。人们开始唱歌，开始拥抱彼此。这非常感人，非常非常感人。
J.J., whose travel arrangements and suite at the Fontainebleau Hotel in Miami were provided free of charge, says he enjoyed his afternoon with the survivors. He was the hero, the man who had made the right choice.
J.J.说他很享受与幸存者共度的那个下午，他的差旅安排和迈阿密枫丹白露酒店的套房都是免费提供的。他是英雄，那个做出了正确选择的人。
They were thanking me and telling me I did the right thing, and there should be more people like me that had put principle before money. Of course I was crying out of one eye and laughing out of the other.
他们感谢我，告诉我我做对了，应该有更多像我这样把原则置于金钱之上的人。当然我是一只眼哭，另一只眼笑。
What do you mean by that?
你这话是什么意思？
Well, you know, there's $500,000 going down the pipe there. And you always have second thoughts even though I wouldn't have taken the money. But it's something to think of when somebody is reminding you every hour.
嗯，你知道，那里有50万美元付诸东流。而且即使我不会要那笔钱，你总会有一些想法。但当有人每小时提醒你时，这还是值得想一想的。
Abe Resnick also apparently enjoyed the day. His son, Jimmy, says he was elated.
阿比·雷斯尼克显然也很享受那一天。他的儿子吉米说他欣喜若狂。
I remember vividly what my father had said and what everybody had said was this will finally be the end of it. After this, that's it. Nothing will come back to haunt us.
我清楚地记得我父亲说过的话，大家说过的话就是，这终于会成为结局。在这之后，就是这样了。没有什么会回来困扰我们了。
As I said, I went down to Jacksonville to visit J.J. and we spent two days in his truck driving around. There was no particular plan to our driving. I had mentioned that I wanted a tour of the city. And so J.J. gave me one. He showed me the Northside of town, where rich people lived in Spanish mansions with water views.
正如我所说，我去了杰克逊维尔拜访J.J.，我们在他的卡车里待了两天，到处转悠。我们的开车路线没有什么特别的计划。我提到过我想参观一下这座城市。于是J.J.带我参观了一下。他带我看了城的北边，那里有钱人住在有水景的西班牙豪宅里。
Then he drove me down to the neighborhood where the Ostwind had spent its last days, to the dock he didn't own anymore. Over the 12 years since the sinking a lot had changed. J.J.'s house had burned down. And the popular seafood restaurant his sister had owned was closed and just beginning to crumble.
然后他开车带我去了“东风”号度过最后日子的那个街区，到了他不再拥有的那个码头。在沉没后的12年里，很多事情都改变了。J.J.的房子被烧毁了。他姐姐拥有的那家受欢迎的海鲜餐厅也关门了，开始变得破败不堪。
J.J. pulled into the lot next to his old place, a small junky yard filled with rusted cars and boats of all shapes and sizes. There was a little girl playing in the yard, dragging a long jumprope back and forth in the dust. There was also a man who looked like her father, 30, maybe 35, with his jeans hanging low on his body and his hands covered in boat grease. J.J. pulled alongside this man and rolled down his window.
J.J.开进了他老地方旁边的地块，一个堆满了生锈汽车和各种形状、大小船只的小废品场。有一个小女孩在院子里玩，在尘土中拖着一根长跳绳来回跑。还有一个看起来像她父亲的男人，30岁，也许35岁，牛仔裤垂在身上，手上沾满了船用油脂。J.J.把车开到那个男人旁边，摇下车窗。
I want to pull over on the other side where the fire station is going to be built, show the little lady some of this stuff if you don't mind.
我想在那边消防站要建的地方靠边停车，如果不介意的话，给这位小女士看看这些东西。
Soon J.J. and the man fell to talking-- about the weather, about nothing in particular. Then J.J. mentioned that he used to own the next lot. And the man nodded his head. He said he remembered J.J. and mentioned the boat that used to sit in the yard.
很快J.J.和那个男人聊了起来——谈论天气，谈论一些无关紧要的事。然后J.J.提到他过去拥有隔壁的地块。男人点了点头。他说他记得J.J.，提到了以前停在院子里的那艘船。
You remember that boat, Hitler's yacht?
你记得那艘船吗，希特勒的游艇？
Yeah, I got a piece of wood off of it.
是的，我从上面拿了一块木头。
Oh, you were one of those thieves.
哦，你是那些小偷之一。
No, you gave it to me.
不，是你给我的。
The man said he took the wood in the Ostwind's last days when its death was all but certain. He said by the time he got to it most of the interesting stuff, the portholes, for example, had already been stripped away by more enterprising souvenir hunters and he had grabbed what he could.
那个人说他在“东风”号最后日子里拿了木头，当时它的死亡已成定局。他说等他去的时候，大部分有趣的东西，比如舷窗，已经被更积极的纪念品猎人剥离掉了，他只能抓到什么拿什么。
It was just Hitler's boat over there. And everybody wanted a piece of it. So I went over and got me my piece of it. It was a piece of teak off the deck.
那儿只有希特勒的船。每个人都想要它的一块。所以我走过去，拿了属于我的一块。那是甲板上的一块柚木。
Where do you keep the little piece of teak now? Do you know?
你现在把那块柚木存放在哪里？你知道吗？
I think it's in the trunk of that car right there.
我想就在那辆车的后备箱里。
Really?
真的吗？
Yes, I think so.
是的，我想是这样。
Can we see it?
我们可以看看吗？
If I can get my trunk open, you can see.
如果我能打开后备箱，你就能看到。
Which one are you in?
你是在哪一辆车里？
I'm in that little Mustang. The lock is broken on it. It might be lying in the back. You want me to look around?
我在那辆小野马里。锁坏了。它可能躺在后面。你想让我看看吗？
The teak wasn't in the backseat. It was in the trunk. And there was no way to get it out. But I didn't mind much. At the time, I thought this was just a pretty piece of coincidence, some dumb luck without any real significance, kind of funny actually. I didn't realize it was the beginning of a pattern, that at almost every stop in Jacksonville, we would find some remnant or echo of Hitler's yacht stored away in car trunks or kitchen cabinets, wrapped in cloth, and laid carefully alongside family silver.
柚木不在后座。它在后备箱里。没法把它拿出来。但我不在乎。当时，我觉得这只是一个美丽的巧合，一些没有任何实际意义的愚蠢运气，实际上挺有趣的。我没意识到这是一种模式的开始，在杰克逊维尔的每一站，我们都会在汽车后备箱或厨房柜子里找到关于希特勒游艇的一些残余或回音，包裹在布里，小心地放在家庭银器旁边。
After the man in the boatyard, there was Howard, a wrinkled old man who showed me the wood from the deck of the Ostwind he'd stored in one of his outbuildings. He told me he didn't believe that Hitler was ever on the boat but had decided to keep the wood anyway.
在造船厂的那个人之后，还有霍华德，一个皱纹满面的老头，他向我展示了他从“东风”号甲板上拆下的木头，存放在他的一间外屋里。他告诉我他不相信希特勒曾经上过那艘船，但还是决定保留这些木头。
After Howard, there was Walter.
在霍华德之后，还有沃尔特。
Hey, Hey. How you doing?
嘿，嘿。你好吗？
J.J. and Walter had known each other for a long time, ever since Walter was a kid and worked on J.J.'s dock. When we drove up he was out front draining the oil from a car parked in his driveway. But as soon as he spied us, he marched out to the street and asked me what I was doing with a tape recorder in my lap.
J.J.和沃尔特认识很久了，自从沃尔特还是个孩子，在J.J.的码头上工作时。我们开车过去时，他正在前面给停在车道上的车排机油。但一看到我们，他就走到街上，问我为什么怀里放着录音机。
When I told him I was talking to people about Hitler's yacht, he smiled and said he had a funny story about that.
当我告诉他我正在和人们谈论希特勒的游艇时，他笑了，说他有一个关于这个的有趣故事。
Yeah, I went to a garage sale I guess about maybe a month ago. And the strangest thing happened at the garage sale. I noticed this dish sitting up there. And the guy said, I cannot tell you who owned the dish. But it came off the Ostwind.
是的，我大概一个月前去参加了一个车库大甩卖。在那次拍卖上发生了最奇怪的事情。我注意到这个盘子放在那儿。那个家伙说，我不能告诉你谁拥有这个盘子。但它来自“东风”号。
The lady that donated to the church the particular item, her dad worked on the Ostwind as one of Hitler's servants.
那个把这个特定物品捐给教会的女士，她爸爸曾在“东风”号上作为希特勒的仆人工作。
Did you get the dish?
你得到那个盘子了吗？
I've got the dish. I'm hanging on to it.
我得到了那个盘子。我一直保存着。
I forgot he told me about that.
我忘了他说过这件事。
Walter disappeared into the house and returned carrying a small bowl. It had a top with a decorated handle and a trim of braided metal a dirty yellowish color.
沃尔特消失在屋里，又带出来一个细小的碗。它有一个带装饰把手的盖子，饰边是脏黄色的编织金属。
That's gold and that's gold. To check it I went ahead and put acid. Because gold will not deteriorate under acid. If it's fake gold, the acid will eat it up. But this right here, I put acid on that and that, sulfuric acid, and nothing happened.
那是金子，那是金子。为了检查它，我直接用了酸。因为金子在酸下不会分解。如果是假金子，酸会把它腐蚀掉。但这个嘛，我用硫酸在那上面滴了，结果什么也没发生。
Walter held the bowl up with both hands so we could get a good look at it. It twinkled and shimmered a little in the late afternoon light. And it was clear from the proud way he held it high in the air that Walter believed the dish was authentic. I, on the other hand, wasn't so sure, especially after he told me he'd only paid $3 for it.
沃尔特用双手举起碗，让我们仔细看看。它在午后的阳光下闪烁着微光。从他骄傲地举起它的方式来看，沃尔特显然相信这个碗是正品。另一方面，我却不太确定，特别是在他说他只花了3美元买下它之后。
But I was going to have it checked out to see if it was authentic. But I have ideas it's authentic. See the thing on the back? I was going to take it to an antique dealer and see what he said about it.
但我会去鉴定一下看看它是否是正品。但我有预感它是真的。看到背后的那个东西了吗？我打算把它带给古董商，看看他怎么说。
After four months of research, I called Rabbi Konovitch, the man who helped Abe Resnick organize the sinking of the Ostwind, and told him I believed that Hitler's yacht was a fraud. I explained the boat's history and made clear I thought that the Ostwind had gotten the name Hitler's yacht because one of its owners realized the name would add to its mystique and value.
经过四个月的研究，我打电话给拉比科诺维奇，那个帮助阿比·雷斯尼克组织沉船的人，告诉他我认为希特勒的游艇是一个骗局。我解释了船的历史，并明确表示我认为“东风”号是因为其中一位船主意识到这个名字会增加其神秘感和价值才被命名为希特勒游艇的。
I see, interesting.
我明白了，很有趣。
So my question for you is does that change your feelings about whether or not the yacht should've been sunk?
所以我给你的问题是，这会改变你对那艘游艇是否应该被沉没的看法吗？
Not at all, because it was merely a symbol to begin with.
一点也不，因为它起初仅仅是一个象征。
Can you expand on that a little bit?
你能稍微展开说明一下吗？
Well, a symbol is very powerful. It doesn't make any difference whether it's historically valid as long as it's a symbol. So for the setting, for the moment, that symbolized Hitler's regime and its destruction.
嗯，象征是非常强大的。它在历史上是否有效并不重要，只要它是一个象征。所以对于那个设定，那一刻，它象征着希特勒的政权及其毁灭。
I had expected a different reaction-- anger, disbelief, or outrage that the survivors had been duped, perhaps even some kind of remorse. I certainly didn't expect amusement and indifference, didn't expect the rabbi wouldn't care. But he was unequivocal. It didn't make any difference to him that the yacht wasn't real. The point, after all, was that the yacht had become a gathering ground for Hitler lovers and misdirected neo-Nazis. Once these people embraced the fantasy of Hitler's yacht, there was no turning back. The Ostwind would be sunk, and its sinking as meaningful as if it were the real thing.
我期待着不同的反应——愤怒、不相信或因为幸存者被愚弄而感到愤怒，甚至某种悔恨。我当然没料到是好笑和冷漠，没料到拉比会不在乎。但他态度坚决。游艇是不是真的对他来说毫无影响。毕竟，重点是游艇已经成为了希特勒崇拜者和误入歧途的新纳粹分子的聚集地。一旦这些人拥抱了希特勒游艇的幻想，就没有回头路了。“东风”号注定要沉没，它的沉没和它是真的一样具有意义。
There's a biblical injunction about destroying entirely evil because if you don't it comes back to haunt you.
有一个关于彻底摧毁邪恶的圣经诫命，因为如果你不这样做，它就会回来缠着你。
The rabbi told me that he thought all Nazi materials, real or fake, should meet the same end as Hitler's yacht. Then he suggested that I read the biblical story of the Amalekites. He thought it might give me some perspective.
拉比告诉我，他认为所有的纳粹材料，无论真假，都应该和希特勒的游艇有相同的下场。然后他建议我阅读亚玛力人的圣经故事。他认为这可能会给我一些视角。
Like the Nazis, the Amalekites sought the eradication and enslavement of the Jewish people. They met often in the open desert for battle. And when the Israelites won one of these fights, there was an absolute rule governing their behavior. They were instructed to obliterate any and all items which might have been captured in the heat of battle. Everything-- trinkets, jewelry, gold, silver-- anything that the Amalekites revered was to be destroyed, even if its acquisition might profit the Jewish victors or help them in their future battles.
像纳粹一样，亚玛力人寻求灭绝和奴役犹太人民。他们经常在开阔的沙漠中战斗。当以色列人赢得其中一场战斗时，有一条绝对的规则支配他们的行为。他们被指示消灭任何可能在激战中缴获的物品。一切——饰品、珠宝、金子、银子——任何亚玛力人所尊崇的东西都必须被摧毁，即使其获取可能使犹太胜利者获利或帮助他们未来的战斗。
I think it's like touching poison. It has to rub off on you either consciously or unconsciously. That's dangerous.
我认为这就像触摸毒药。它必须在有意识或无意识中感染你。那是危险的。
So after I talked to the rabbi, I called Walter back. I wanted to see if he was being poisoned by evil, corrupted by the presence of the $3 bowl he stored on the shelf in his bedroom. I asked Walter why he wanted the dish, if it was simply the drama of celebrity which excited him, any celebrity, or if his interest was more specific, if there was something about Hitler in particular.
在和拉比谈过之后，我给沃尔特回了电话。我想看看他是否正在被邪恶毒害，被他放在卧室架子上的那个3美元的碗腐蚀。我问沃尔特为什么想要那个盘子，是因为明星效应的戏剧性让他兴奋，任何明星，还是说他的兴趣更具体，如果希特勒有什么特别的东西。
Do you think you'd rather have a dish from Hitler or from John F. Kennedy?
你觉得你更想要希特勒的盘子，还是约翰·F·肯尼迪的？
Oh boy. Well, I think you'd get more value out of the one that Hitler had, as far as the monetary value.
哦，天哪。好吧，我觉得从希特勒那里的东西你会获得更多价值，就货币价值而言。
How about, would you rather have a dish from Hitler or from FDR?
如果是这样，你更想要希特勒的盘子还是罗斯福的？
Oh boy. I think I'd rather have it from Hitler to be honest with you. FDR wasn't all that wise. Hitler was a pretty smart guy. You know, Einstein and him were side by side with intelligence, I believe.
哦，天哪。老实说，我更想要希特勒的。罗斯福并没有那么聪明。希特勒是个相当聪明的人。你知道，爱因斯坦和他并列在智力上，我相信。
I've got one more of these questions. Would you rather have a dish from Churchill or from Hitler?
我还有一个问题。你更想要丘吉尔的盘子还是希特勒的？
Oh boy. I'll stick with Hitler.
哦，天哪。我还是选希特勒。
Do you think that Hitler is cooler than FDR?
你认为希特勒比罗斯福更酷吗？
He was kind of an outlaw. Maybe that's what I like about him. I don't know. But I think Hitler was cooler.
他算是个亡命之徒。也许这就是我喜欢他的原因。我不知道。但我认为希特勒更酷。
And do you think that Hitler was cooler than Kennedy?
你认为希特勒比肯尼迪更酷吗？
Well, Kennedy was born with what they call a silver spoon in his mouth. Adolf Hitler wasn't.
嗯，肯尼迪出生时就含着所谓的银勺子。阿道夫·希特勒则不是。
So you identify with him in that way?
所以你是在那种方式上认同他？
It could be, yeah. Kennedy never had to work an honest day in his life. Whereas Hitler had to work every day of his life. Kennedy did some stuff that I didn't necessarily approve of, like his being an infidel. He was not very true to his wife. He just philandered around. Adolf Hitler didn't philander. He was just a true guy, you know, my kind of guy.
可能是吧，是的。肯尼迪一生中从未做过诚实的一天工作。而希特勒一生中每天都在工作。肯尼迪做了一些我不一定赞同的事情，比如他是个异教徒。他对妻子不够忠诚。他只是到处乱搞。阿道夫·希特勒没乱搞。他只是个真实的人，你知道，我喜欢的那种人。
But he killed six million people.
但他杀了600万人。
Well, I didn't agree with that part of him. He didn't have to do that. He didn't have to kill them. He could have put them in slave camps and just let them be. But to actually exterminate people, that is wrong.
嗯，我不同意他的那部分。他不必那样做。他不必杀了他们。他可以把他们送进奴隶营让他们活着。但真的去消灭人民，那是错的。
Do you think that people are more attracted to evil or more attracted to good?
你认为人们更容易被邪恶吸引还是更容易被善良吸引？
Depends on the person.
因人而异。
Do you think that evil is more exciting than good?
你认为邪恶比善良更令人兴奋吗？
Oh boy. You would have to drag that up. Well, the majority of people are good. Let's put it that way. I think the majority of people want to do good. I try to do good. I go out of my way to be good. But I do have, I guess you could say, a bad part about me.
哦，天哪。你非要翻出来说这个。好吧，大多数人是善良的。我们就这么说吧。我认为大多数人想行善。我努力行善。我尽我所能去做一个好人。但我确实有，你可以说是，坏的一面。
Walter works full-time as a lineman for the electric company. On weekends he goes fishing. He also enjoys fixing cars and long visits with his family. Now Walter is not a neo-Nazi nor is he a fascist. If you ask Walter to explain his fascination with Hitler, he won't talk about Hitler's politics, he'll talk about Hitler's power, that Hitler could quote, "do whatever he wanted."
沃尔特在电力公司全职担任线路员。周末他去钓鱼。他还喜欢修理汽车和与家人进行长时间的探访。现在沃尔特既不是新纳粹也不是法西斯。如果你让沃尔特解释他对希特勒的迷恋，他不会谈论希特勒的政治，他会谈论希特勒的力量，希特勒可以，引用他的话说，“做他想做的任何事。”
What do you think it is that's so--
你认为这是什么……
Fascinating about Hitler?
对希特勒的痴迷？
Yes.
是的。
Well, when you think about what he did, look at the people that he organized just on a whim. He had a million soldiers just like that come up that believed in his views. And how one man can dictate someone's life like that and just get all these people to believe in him and actually go fight a war.
嗯，当你想到他所做的事情时，看看那些他只凭一时兴起就组织起来的人。他有一百万士兵就像那样站了出来，相信他的观点。一个人怎么能那样左右别人的生活，并让所有这些人相信他并真正去打一场战争。
Walter keeps the bowl locked in his bedroom, hidden from thieves, but positioned so that each night when he goes to bed he has a view of it from his pillow. He doesn't show it to people because, he says, he doesn't want to cause trouble between the races. Walter doesn't want to upset anyone. He just likes being close to the dish he believes is a little piece of history.
沃尔特把那个碗锁在卧室里，避开小偷，但摆放的位置使得每晚他上床睡觉时，从枕头上都能看到它。他不向人展示它，因为他说，他不想在不同种族之间制造麻烦。沃尔特不想让任何人感到难过。他只是喜欢接近他认为是历史一小部分的盘子。
To me it's kind of intriguing that I own something that he actually had in his possession. He might have eaten soup out of this stupid bowl. I don't know. It's just something that not everybody has. I mean, do you have a bowl form Hitler?
对我来说，我拥有他实际上拥有的东西这一事实非常有趣。他可能用这只傻碗喝过汤。我不知道。这只是一些不是每个人都有的东西。我的意思是，你有希特勒的碗吗？
I suggested to Walter that the Ostwind wasn't actually Hitler's yacht. I told him I believed that Hitler had never actually set foot on the boat.
我向沃尔特暗示“东风”号实际上并不是希特勒的游艇。我告诉他我相信希特勒实际上从未踏上过那艘船。
Well, now I heard he was on it. And when I was in history class, I remember seeing pictures of him on the Ostwind.
嗯，现在我听说他上过。而且当我在历史课上时，我记得看到过他在“东风”号上的照片。
Oh really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah, I remember seeing a vessel. I wonder what Hitler would think now if he knew I had his bowl.
是的，我记得看到过一艘船。我好奇如果希特勒知道我有他的碗，他现在会怎么想。
Do you ever think about that?
你曾经想过这个问题吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And what do you think?
那你怎么想？
How does this grab you, man? You were on the ship. Your boat is out in the ocean sunk in like 250 feet of water. And I've got the bowl off of it from a guy that you gave it to on the boat. I got it from his daughter. I mean, when you think about it, it's really fascinating.
伙计，这事儿怎么打动你？你曾在船上。你的船现在在离海250英尺深的海底。而我有一个人送的碗，那是你在船上给他的。我从他女儿那里拿到的。我的意思是，当你想到它时，它真的很迷人。
What's fascinating is at the end of the day, it didn't really matter to anyone involved with the Ostwind whether or not the boat or any of the material that came off the boat was real. Both those who reviled Hitler and those who worshipped him had agreed to play out their passions on this half-rotted sailboat. And in doing that, they made the question of its authenticity obsolete. They didn't bother, didn't want really, to think about the possibility that the boat in question was a fraud. The battle they felt they were fighting was too important. And when confronted with evidence that it was a hoax, one side resolutely denied its reality. The other simply didn't seem to care.
迷人的是，在一天结束时，对于任何与“东风”号有关的人来说，这艘船或从船上拿下的任何东西是否是真的，其实并不重要。那些厌恶希特勒的人和那些崇拜他的人都同意在这艘半腐烂的帆船上演绎他们的激情。通过这样做，他们使它是否真实的真实性问题变得过时了。他们没费心，真的不想思考相关船只可能是个欺诈的可能性。他们感觉自己正在进行的战斗太重要了。而当面对它是骗局的证据时，一方坚决否认其现实性。另一方似乎根本不在乎。
And that's where this story ends, this biography of an extended collective fantasy with one postscript. J.J. told me that months after the yacht was scuttled, people continued to write. Many wrote wondering where precisely the boat had been sunk. It seems they wanted to fish it out and stage a resurrection.
故事就在这里结束，这是一段延伸的集体幻想的传记，带有一个后记。J.J.告诉我，在游艇沉没几个月后，人们继续写信。许多人写信询问船到底沉在哪里。似乎他们想把它捞出来并策划一次复活。
J.J., of course, wouldn't say. He told all comers that the yacht was nothing but, and here I quote, "a pain in the ass that made an excellent fishing reef."
J.J.当然不会说。他告诉所有来访者那艘游艇除了，我这里引用，“一个制造了优秀钓鱼礁石的麻烦”外什么也不是。
It made an excellent fishing reef. It's probably just one big barnacle now.
它制造了一个优秀的钓鱼礁石。它现在可能只是一大块藤壶了。
Alix Spiegel, she's a mental health reporter for National Public Radio. Her story was part of a series called the America Project. She got funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
阿利克斯·斯皮格尔，她是国家公共广播电台的心理健康记者。她的故事是系列节目“美国项目”的一部分。她获得了公共广播公司提供的资助。
Our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and me with Wendy Dorr, Jonathan Goldstein, and Starlee Kine, senior producer Julie Snyder, production help form Todd Bachmann, Laura Bellows and Paul McCarthy.
我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布伦伯格和我制作，还有温迪·多尔、乔纳森·戈尔德斯坦和斯塔莉·凯恩，资深制作人朱莉·斯奈德，Todd Bachmann、Laura Bellows和Paul McCarthy提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
You can download today's program at our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who explains why he can't meet with you.
您可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载今天的节目存档。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司分发。WBEZ对我们节目的管理由托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他解释了为什么他不能和你见面。
My wife is a millionaire. She's a nymphomaniac. And she's an alcoholic. And it's all I can do to handle her. I can't put up with you.
我的妻子是百万富翁。她是性欲亢进者。而且她是酒鬼。我能对付她就不错了。我没法忍受你。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI Public Radio International.
PRI公共广播国际公司。